family is also on the minds of our
favorite TV handyman the property
brothers drew and Jonathan Scott they've
got a new children's book so of course
work Anderson had to flash back to their
own very cute childhood joint birthdays
what twins do best the present part when
we were little it was like one present
seriously boy these two were adorable
and these exclusive photos of them as
kids brought up all kinds of stories the
door isn't her mom beautiful he's
gorgeous so if I were to ask your mother
who was the quieter one should probably
say we trade off because we used to when
we're a little younger than that
Jonathan be the leader for a couple
weeks and it was changing you follow me
around all the time but when it came to
mischief she would most likely say it
was more gun yeah Jonathan and drew are
still just a couple of big kids at heart
so they wrote builder brothers big plans
a book about two brothers who build
stuff whose idea was good but I mean
both of ours it was spawned from our
fans we have so many kids that love
watching our shows which it just blows
our minds who would have thought that
kids would like real estate and design
television at five years old I was
playing in the mud I mean kids today are
brilliant
drew and wife Linda tied the knot
earlier this year so since she's now a
children's book author are they planning
on kids of their own soon big family how
many kids do you want to do maybe like
thirteen or fourteen we've said - four
we'll see we'd love to have twins
actually because what for us growing up
we had built-in best friends right here
and so for us to have that mark is
amazing I mean I love these guys they're
my pals and they can do anything
[Music]
[Applause]